[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Georgia
is in Chicago Georgia welcome to the
ramsy
show thank you hello what's going
on um I bought a car the end of July and
I was lied to about the price of the car
um it was some from someone that I go to
church with and um I signed the
contract without looking at it because I
trusted this man and now I can't afford
this
car okay tell me more what do you mean
you were lied to about the cost so they
said it was a certain price and you paid
that price yes they told me on the phone
it was 25,000 okay um um I had gone to
take a trip two days after I bought it
to North Carolina there was some issues
with the car and out of frustration I
was looking at the paperwork I got from
the the sales and noticed that they had
char charged me $7,000 more for the car
than what I was
told okay how I'm so confused as to how
you walked out of there having paid
$32,000 that wasn't a red flag to you
like it came out how did you pay for the
car um I went to my credit union but
like I said it was from someone from my
church and I trusted him so after we had
discussed you know the cost and there
and all the taxes and everything and the
3,000 I was going to get out of my old
car I kind of figured it would take me
down to about 22,000 for the car so
after discussing all this with him and
signed a contract without reading it
because again I trusted this
man so it was out of the frustration
when I pulled the paper out of my glove
box um I noticed that it was 32,000 not
25,000 for the actual price of the car
or did they tack on fees
warranties what made it 3 actual price
what did he say when you called
it he told me that they had had two
other Fort escapes on the
lot and probably just got it mixed
up so what are they going to do to make
it right they ain't G to do
nothing I've contacted multiple I I bet
you I have called 30 lawyers and because
I signed that no there this has nothing
to do with lawyers this has to do with
have you gone up to meet in person with
management not angry and not enraged but
say hey this salesman is a friend of
mine he told me this number he admitted
that they mixed it up he admitted that
they mixed up the cars I want the car
that I discuss with the salesman because
you all switch the cars on
me yes I did and they still refused to
do anything about it even if the
salesman would have told the the manager
that he told me that they still refuse
to do anything about it okay and you've
talked to attorneys and they say
sorry yes okay so if you have a a legal
professional telling you their ethical
duty is to not take your money because
you don't have a case that means you
don't have a
case and sometimes they'll tell you we
don't know that you have a case but we
think we can win this let's figure
something out and what they've all told
you is honey we're not going to take
your money it would be unethical for us
to take your money what does that
mean you found yourself in a quandry and
so I want you to do me a favor okay as
hard as this is going to be I want you
for a while to forget about that man
that you said you trusted because that
doesn't factor into the situation that
you found yourself in now okay did he do
you wrong yes did he lie yes did he not
protect you whatever but you said the
words I kind of figured and then I
signed a contract and that's that as you
as an adult have to say I also signed a
contract without looking at the final
numbers I did take his word but I didn't
do my due diligence also and here I sit
with this thing and now I got to figure
out what to do is that cool cuz what
here's what you're doing that anger and
that rage that you have however
Justified and right it is he's off doing
his thing it's only poisoning you right
yes so let's do our best to set that
down however righteous and unjust it is
you got to do bu a car that you can't
afford So when you say you can't afford
it what does that
mean
um it's actually the price of the car
was 32,000 but by the time you I
attached a warranty on that I'm up to
38,000 now what is the loan
amount um if I wait seven years $48,000
no not if you wait seven years what was
the loan amount you took
out uh 38 okay and what is your
income uh it's 31 uh 3,100 a month okay
and what is the car worth
today um I'm going to guess around
25,000 okay here's the deal you bought
too much car anyways even if it was
25,000 and so here's what you can do you
could probably get rid of that warranty
and they can refund you for that you can
leave Yelp reviews you can call the
local news and get into a story but at
the end of the day you got to realize I
got to pay a stupid tax I played a giant
role in this conundrum and you might
have to sell it and eat the cost of that
and come up with the difference to get
rid of this loan and get a reasonable
car but you sure learned your lesson
you're always going to read the fine
print of every single thing you sign for
the rest of your life and I'm sorry that
you had to learn it a hard way